we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p this is a
kind of a weird let me see if I can
explain this and maybe you can help me
out with this path so a couple months
ago we got a voicemail from someone was
it someone claiming to be Bret Keene or
was it someone who sounded like Brett
Keynes
someone who sounded like Brett Keene and
then many members of her audience
pointed out that that was Brett Keene
turned out it wasn't though okay
so who is Brett Keene because I still am
unsure he's a youtuber right youtuber he
was the chief antagonist of the drunken
peasants show I don't know if he still
is but he's in that Network along with
like amazing atheist and those folks
yeah okay so we got a voicemail over the
weekend from someone saying a Brett
Keene impersonator called you before
that wasn't me
this really is me so now Brett Keene is
actually calling but to clarify that
before the guy who people thought was
Brett Keene actually wasn't he also left
his phone number in the voicemail which
of course we bleeped out I guess because
that would allow me to prove that this
is the real Brett Keene let's take a
listen hello my name is Brett key and
yes this is a real Brett Keene if you'd
like to get a hold of me and find out
that this is the official Brett Keene
you can contact me as I noticed you guys
made a video a while back where he had
some impersonator I have a lot of
impersonators and people who imitate me
yeah I guess it's because I'm famous and
beautiful in all wonders I'd love to
have a conversation with you alright god
bless ya so you were very confident Pat
that the last person was Brett Keene it
is do you think this is actually Brett
Keene and by the way I don't even know
how I would figure that out for sure by
calling him because it might just sound
like Brett Keene so I should clarify the
very first person who called in some
people in the audience suspected it was
Brett Keene that wasn't Brett Keene then
the actual Brett Keene shortly
thereafter caught wind of all this and
he called in himself personally so the
second call that we received was the
actor
Brett Keane I do believe that this is
the actual Brett Keane as well the
question is do we want to have him on
the show for an interview to talk about
I guess his life's work and I'll leave
that up to you David
I don't think we do but so what you're
saying is the real Brett Keane is called
in twice I don't remember that yeah
that's that first breaking phone call
we'll have to check the phone records
but yeah this is now his second time
leaving a voicemail with us man I have
no clue what's going on on this show I
have no idea I do i thought this was I
probably wouldn't even have played this
if I remembered that the actual Brett
Keenan called in before okay anyway
we'll cut out this entire segment from
the version that goes out to the public
we've got a great bonus show for you
today
New England Patriots owner Robert Kraft
charged with soliciting prostitution
between his Trump athelia and this I
don't really have any kind of soft spot
for Robert Kraft any more much more to
also discuss on the bonus show
patreon.com slash david pakman show to
get access or membership ww join
pakman.com email me for half price
memberships and a limited limited number
of totally free memberships I will speak
to you on the bonus show